[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the job
assist webinar for EWS course
my name is priyamvada and I am your host
for the session okay I believe we are
good to start so let me transfer the
present actress Tanisha Prix who heads
the job Asus team in our organization
all right
hello everyone I am the screen heading
job versus programme and simply learn I
welcome you all again to our job assist
webinar we are really lucky to have
Nitin one of the best mentor with us
today who will be guiding you through
the nuances of AWS and he will also
detail you on the market trend in AWS
technologies we are really fortunate to
have our partner from liberal payment
who will be making you aware of do's and
don'ts in your interviews and he will
also tell you how to make your first
impression in your job interview this
session is going to be really helpful
and informative and I hope we will be
having a lot to grasp and learn from
this webinar I would actually like to
without any delay I would like to pass
on the presented access to our mentor
Nitin thank you so much nothing for
accepting our request to take this
webinar on weekend thank you so much for
giving us on your your time on weekends
thank you so much I'm just giving you
the present in your access all right
time say Street and again to all of my
fellow students welcome again to this
webinar just so quick confirmation from
all of you if you are able to hear me
properly and again if you are able to
see my screen as well I just quick
confirmation from all of you all right
so I believe that I'm audible to all of
you and those were being so amazing my
wife is little lows around there I try
to speak a little louder so I hope
that's clear to you as well now all
right guys so without wasting too much
time on other things so that this you
know this program is all about I believe
that all of you have already gone to you
know one of the course
simply learned regarding AWS and you
already know a lot more on eight years
now compared to what you have been doing
with before going to this courses now
this program is primarily for I get a
lot of questions from students during
the course as well that you know if I
certify and how to certify and when to
certify and if I certify that how I'm
going to get got a job in cloud
computing so we have seen that this is
has been a trend in almost all the
courses that everybody has this golden
question that one that goes of this
course once I clear my certification I
am going to get a job in cloud computing
so this program is basically to help you
for it basically to help you and as well
as guide you on how you can crack a job
in cloud computing so the agenda of this
courses number one will give it
orientation on what cloud computing of
the cloud technology is all about we'll
talk about basic terminologies in cloud
computing so this is something that you
must have already gone through if you
have gone through the courses on simply
learn but if we have any of the
participants who are not yet registered
for our courses so this is just to give
you a oversight on what do we mean by
cloud computing what we mean by
different general trends within cloud
computing in terms of public cloud
versus private cloud etcetera and so on
and then we are also going to talk about
market trends and that's primarily again
to give you a you know kind of a
feel-good factor that in case if you are
decided to move on to you know cloud
computing which you are decided to
pursue your career in your AWS very
great here do you stand in terms of how
many companies are actually looking
forward to move their infrastructure on
cloud move their workloads on to the
cloud and what are the type of jobs that
they're going to come up with what is
the current market you know how the
current market looks like in terms of
job opportunities within cloud computing
and so on and then we are going to give
you a little bit more insight into
different rules and responsibilities
which are you know available within
cloud building market so of course I'm
not going to say that you know once
you've heard this education you can go
ahead and pay for any of the job
interviews and you know which are
available in in the market for cloud
computing of course you do need to have
some
of expertise you were able to have some
level of experience as well you know to
go with your certification as well but
yes what we will be doing is we will
kind of you know putting our different
jobs in two different categories
depending upon the job the overall IT
experience that you have you can
basically map your IT experience plus
your certification with the job roles
that are available in the market so
rather than applying all the jobs which
are available on cloud computing you can
do a more targeted search when it comes
to looking for opportunities in the
cloud computing and then we are going to
talk about top public cloud providers we
are going to give you a comparison of
you know what about different cloud
computing or public cloud providers
available in the market and we have this
stand in terms of noted performance in
terms of their you know market capture
or market goals and so on and then I
will be basically you know covering all
this up and then we'll have a small
break and not a break but from primarily
a Q&A round in case if you have any
specific questions to ask for me and
once we do the Q&A round I'm going to
pass on the presenting rights to one of
our partners from the pro who will
basically you know take you through in
terms of how to prepare your CV how to
you know look for a targeted job search
and how to you know come up with it to
where for your interview in case if you
do get shortlisted for interviews so
what are the different things that you
need to do so kind of do's and don'ts
for your profile for your CV and so on
and lastly again we are going to talk
about different partners that works with
simply learned as far as cloud computing
is concerned and probably again will
pass on the presenting rise to display
we should take you through to the
placement assistance services which are
available for any of the participants
who have gone through single enforce and
who have got the certified certification
from simply learn as well as you know
certification from AWS right
so with that let's get started so first
thing first introductions and I do
notice that a lot of participants who
have probably do remember the name so
there's some participant to have already
called enrolled in my courses so just
just an application for them but
primarily my name is Nathan so I am a
solution
a data file a double a solution
architect associate certify databases
opposite associate as well as certified
it against developer associate as well
and apart from I'm passionate about the
cloud computing so apart from my
experience of what from my
certifications in AWS I am also a
certified Google cloud since of
professional act as well that I was
already looking forward to my
certifications and a zero as well
followed by my certifications on you
know as a solution are trained
professional as well so cloud computing
is my forte cloud computing is my
passion I do read a lot on cloud
computing if I'm not doing anything most
of the time I'm spending my time reading
about different articles which are
published on cloud computing market
so pretty much I will say that I am in a
good position to kind of you know guide
you in terms of yourself computing
market is going whatever different
trends that we are seeing in cloud
computing market and how you as a
student can capture those trends so that
can help you in you know we are
progressing you career further as well
in terms of my experience I have more
than 15 years of experience within IT
industry so I've worked as a you know
all different roles with different
companies so of course have worked in
postal work increases I worked as a
project team members and most
importantly I've worked with multiple
organization as a cloud architect where
have helped them to move their workload
plan their movement onto the cloud so
when we are saying that more of many
companies are planning their workload
onto the cloud what we are saying is if
the companies have their infrastructure
on their own data center or any
third-party data centers to cut down the
cost primarily to cut down the cost they
are moving their infrastructure onto the
cloud and this is people like me who are
working working as a knight IT architect
or cloud architect or solution architect
has them plan that moment that what are
services you should be using in cloud
how you will migrate how much time is
corrected how destructive this movement
will be or how to ensure that if you
want to move your workload on to the
cloud that what are the steps you need
to take whatever you know relevant tools
that you need to use etcetera and so on
now apart from my IT experience of
course Amma you know the facilitator and
trainer on AWS cloud computing as well
more than 10 plus years of
experience and training industry hype
campaigns like Sentinel in creating
content and you know coming up with a
lot of webinars or skill development
work shows and I'm sure that you know
some of you have already attended my
webinars or my you know trainings so you
know that what I'm talking about so you
can say that I'm a cloud architect and a
consultant working you know with the
large organization as well as helping
other students get this you handle feet
within the cloud computing market as
well now what we are going to start with
is we are going to talk about some of
the basic terminologies which are you
know prevalent in the market now this is
something that you would be probably
already know if you have understand if
you have gone to any of the courses or
even if you are working in IT industry
you may have heard this terms
repetitively as well but what we are
going to do is and this is probably
going to be a very first interview
question that you will get from most of
the companies I am sure how much will
agree with me agree with me on this as
well that whenever anyone is appearing
for any interview within the computing
within the cloud world I think this is
one of the most frequently asked
questions and then in the interviews so
what do you mean by cloud computing what
do we mean by public cloud what is the
difference between a public cloud and a
private cloud and what do we win by
hybrid cloud cloud as well so when we
talk about cloud computing this is not a
new term which has been devised operat
lis in fact this has been prevalent from
quite some time more than 10 years over
the very rough estimate if I can say so
and the way IT industry works is and
that's kind of funny as well they keep
coming up with new acronym turkey coming
up with new buzzwords in the industry so
when we talk about cloud computing so
what we mean is that rather than
deploying your infrastructure that
Infosys they can be your servers use
your your switches your router's your
firewall your storage your databases
etcetera and so on rather than deploying
that infrastructure on your own office
premises on your own data center in your
own environment you are deploying it at
some other location and that location is
not something which is owned by you that
location is not something which is
management
you even when we talk about
infrastructure stand infrastructure may
not be directly managed by you probably
this is managed by some other third
party so for example previously but when
we never had this AWS or Azure or you
know you know for that matter any of
your Google Data Center sets and so on
what we used to have is lot of companies
in this space I'm talking about
companies like the pro TCS IBM Dell HP
the T etc and so on or for that matter
companies like net magic your you know
controller six a transform which used to
have their own data centers around the
world and they would you know approach a
company and say that you can host your
infrastructure within our datacenter as
well
so if I have to put it very very in a
layman language cloud computing is
basically a practice of using remote
servers or remote resources and
connecting to those resources using some
kind of connectivity that connectivity
can be internet or that connectivity can
also be a private connectivity like
leaving and being asleep in the set and
so on but the bottom line is that all of
your infrastructure on which you are
deploying your business critical
applications your deploying your
resources that infrastructure is not
owned by you that infrastructure is
basically owned by someone else and they
are being managed by someone else
however they may have we may have some
variations in it some of the providers
they do come up with you know different
what you call their own offers as well
in those offer they may say that you
will you can be the owner of your
hardware as well as well but at the end
of the day you will not be responsible
for day-to-day operation or day to make
building management of that hardware
from all of your interception so that's
what cloud computing is all about so I
do get this funny question from someone
that you know infra citrus somewhere in
the cloud so this is north cloud this is
still being deployed on our own planet
earth and this is still being deployed
on some kind of data centers which are
being run which are being maintained and
managed by some of the you know
specialized IT companies that are named
a few right so that
- cloud computing now after cloud
computing then we have variants of cloud
computing so we can didn't cloud
computing we can have a public lump or
we can have a private cloud or we can
also have a hybrid cloud as well so what
do we mean by public cloud this is again
a type of cloud computing model but in
this case we are talking about service
service providers like a dub here's like
a zoos like Google etcetera and so on
now what do we mean by public cloud over
here public cloud means that anyone even
if you are a student you can also go
ahead and deploy your resources even if
that resources is one single server or
one single website you can go ahead and
deploy those resources on all on one of
the public clouds as well so it is a
same form of cloud computing that
companies like it appears as your your
Google Facebook etcetera and so on they
have their own data centers they have
deployed the server the databases the
network storage and set and so on and
then they have opened it to the public
that you can come in and deploy whatever
you want you can use any of the services
that you want and you will only be
paying for the services that you are
using
there will be no upfront investment that
you have to make compared I mean there
are a lot of startups which are coming
up notice I will startup industry is
booming at the stage especially in India
as well nothing from the startup
standpoint that typically every startup
they have a idea that they want to
implement right they probably have the
skills in terms of you know coding
language in terms of you know whatever
applications or you know data that they
want to have but normally the starters
will not have a lot of capital a lot of
money that they could invest in in
setting up and setting up of their data
center that involves a lot of money if
you want to set up your own data center
so rather than you know doing all this
you know setting up of data center
looking for a place and taking care of
your cabling taking care of racking
taking care of your cooling temperature
etcetera and so on what you can do is
you can deploy your infrastructure on
one of the public cloud where they have
already created they have already
the parlour of souls and you can go on
and kind of rent those you know devices
from public cloud providers and then you
can deploy any type of application that
you are looking for on this public law
provider so again some of the key words
that you can throw in when you're
defining public cloud that public cloud
providers are something it is first of
all it is a paper use model you will
only be paying for what you use if you
want to deploy your resources for two
hours you will pay for two hours only if
you are deploying it for ten days you'll
only pay for ten days and so on and
secondly whatever you are deploying you
will be accessing that more those
applications those devices over the
Internet
however for enterprise customers who do
not want to connect it over the Internet
you can also have private connectivity
as well that is also one of the
additional features or one of the
features within your public cloud
providers as well and when we talk about
public cloud providers as I said eight
of us as your Google probably are one of
the you know at the top C contenders for
you know public log providers
now the second variant of cloud
computing is your private cloud again
this is a cloud computing only as I said
that the weak public cloud has came into
picture is because of the private cloud
deployment of the cause of the cloud
computing deployment because of the
companies like Wipro TCS IBM HP Dell and
so on who used to have their own data
center and they used to deploy that
stuff all those data center but
primarily the end customer in this case
is not any everyone the end customer is
going to be specific enterprise
customers who need to have a certain set
of requirement will need to you know
deploy certain set of servers of course
you can have a small customer you can
have a big customer but primarily that
end customer is not for example a
student or a startup in this case I mean
anyone who has little bit more pockets a
little bit more money that's what they
want to apply private Wells another
point worth mentioning is when we have
when we are dealing with different
industries when you are dealing with
let's say banking finance and so on
there may be some industries who may
have some kind of you know kind of
regulatory requirements that you know
kind of you know
that did not allow them to deploy their
infrastructure on public clothes right
in those cases they can probably choose
private cloud deployment as well wherein
you have the complete control of you're
interested in public cloud your
infrastructure will be owned will be
managed by the cloud provider but in
private cloud you may have a variations
where you can completely own and
completely manager and position yourself
as well or you can let it be managed by
the third-party companies as well so
primarily the benefit that you get is
most importantly is the security part is
the segregation part that whatever you
deploy on private cloud
it may be dedicated to a single
organization you may not have any other
organization sharing the workload on
private self whereas in public cloud you
may be you know for example deploying
virtual machines and those virtual
machines probably will be running on
some kind of physical server but one
physical server may be hosting virtual
machine from different clients as well
having said that of course there is a
segregation layer available within the
objects out as well but just for some
companies were more prone to security
they may opt for private cloud
deployment as well
right and the best benefit that you get
so private cloud deployment is you can
basically deploy your own architecture
it's totally up to you how you want to
design your interesting what you want to
put in the those data centers you have
the complete control in that case the
third is hybrid clouds and that is
probably from my experience standpoint
will be the most deployed computing
model in the market as of now I have not
seen a single organization are not come
across a single organization which has
the complete infrastructure on private
cloud or which has a complete
infrastructure on a public so typically
the combination of public cloud and a
private cloud is what we call it as
hybrid cloud environment in other word
you may have a deployment which you may
have deployed in a processor on your own
premises on your own data centers or you
may have deployed your infrastructure on
one of the private cloud you know data
centers and some of the infrastructure
on public road as well
typically you will see that most of the
authorization will start deploying there
in position public cloud they would
always start with deploying the
business-critical as they will always
have your business physical applications
on Prem or on private cloud whereas
their Dell and password which are not as
the security requirements are not as
stringent as business critical
application they will always have your
dev and test environment on public cloud
then we have different models different
services of 12 so we have infrastructure
as a service model we have platform as a
service model and we have software as a
service model so what we mean by these
three models again another very very
important or very very commonly asked
questions in the interview what do we
mean by infrastructure as a service
model is this is again a type of cloud
computing where you can pick up I
normally call it as a pick and choose
model so you can pick and choose what
services you want to use as far as
infrastructure is concerned which means
I want to deploy a database you can go
out and pick a database I want to deploy
a server you can go out and pick it so
if you want to deploy a load balancer
you can go ahead and deploy a load
balancer so of course all of these
resources are still virtualized all of
these resources may or may not be shared
depending upon how you're using it but
most importantly you can pick and choose
what services you want to use that is
your infrastructure as a service model
the next model is platform as a service
so platform as a service model comes one
layer above then you're in furniture as
a service model again in this particular
model you will be picky you will be
choosing in the runtime environment we
typically call it as a runtime
environment that you want to deploy
again whatever is at the infrastructure
layer in terms of servers to a database
network and so on that will also be part
of your platform but apart from this
standard infrastructure component you
may also have something called your
runtime environment which can be let's
say your PHP stack let's say you are you
know nodejs stack let's say you're you
know dotnet stack etcetera and so on now
once you have this platform ready as a
service then you if you want to deploy a
PHP application you all you need is
your application code and then you
deploy that application code unfilled on
top of your platform of course when
you're talking about platform as a
service model the architecture of your
application is already predefined
or there is a standardized architecture
that everyone will use in that case you
cannot change your architecture if you
want to change your architectures you
should typically be picking up in first
across the service model where you can
go ahead and kind of you know pick and
choose what services I want to use in my
infrastructure and last model is
software as a service model where you
can again in some skill is covered
platform is covered on top of it even
the software that you want to deploy
even the application that you want to
deploy even that application is already
pre-installed or predefined for you your
you will only get the subscription for
those applications typical example let's
say you are deploying Gmail so everyone
can go ahead and get a gmail account
everyone will get the similar look and
feel of the gmail account if you are a
business customer and you are looking
for let's say corporate email account on
Gmail you can go ahead and say that I
have 125 accounts of what 8 pounds or 50
counts and so on but everyone will get
the same look and feel you don't have to
install the Gmail client for all of your
users
right or it can be Salesforce for
example as well again Salesforce is an
application which is already pre
deployed for you or your hotel is
normally subscription yet getting it for
that particular application so this is
your infrastructure as a service model
platform as a service model and software
is a service module then comes to market
tips so very cloud computing market
heading so if you look at the world wide
spreading so this is one of the you know
studies which has been done by Vicky
bonds they basically kind of analyze the
public and private clouds research
products and find out how much money
companies are willing to expend on you
are deploying this public and hybrid
cloud and so on so what they have found
is it the worldwide spending on public
cloud will continue to grow at more than
90 19.5 or approximately 30 percent
year-on-year
and it can go grow up to 132 billion in
2019 and by 228 billion by 2026 and
probably I will see I will say that
these numbers are very very restrictive
you may end up or companies may end up
spending a lot more than that the way
the startup industry is booming and
lastly your public cloud ear adoption is
3.5 times more than private cloud and
that's something that you should also I
mean you can also notice if you look
closely or if you kind of you know read
through the you know different articles
which are prevalent in the market today
you will notice that lot of private sold
companies the companies that are named
tcsh HP Dell etcetera and so on they are
actually entering into an agreement with
some of the public cloud providers as
well so they may have an agreement with
AWS or a0 Google and so on so they are
kind of partnering with them to deploy
their claims on public cloud as well so
that's that it goes up there's a lot of
cost ranging involved when you are
deploying your services on public cloud
versus private clouds and another most
important factor is the amount of
innovation and the pace of innovation
with which your public law providers are
coming up it's humongous and probably
private cloud players may not be able to
compete with that pace so that's the
reason that companies are looking
forward to moving the interest beyond
the public load compared to private
however they will private cloud market
will continue to prevail they will
continue to have use cases where
probably they have more security
requirements are more stringent you know
security requirement those case of
course there will be customers who would
want to deploy on private cloud as well
so private cloud is market is going to
be estimated at 65 billion by 2026 if we
have a look at the cloud computing job
trends so there are more than 18 million
jobs available worldwide so that's the
current job volume that we have analyzed
within China we have more than 7.4
million jobs within us we are both
approximately 4 million jobs within
India alone we have more than 2.2
million jobs available across our Indian
geography
and industries again I would say that
these are just the high-level the you
talk about ITU manufacturing retail
finance healthcare banking you talk
about insurance most of the companies
are moving their work load onto the
cloud whether it is public or a private
cloud and they are looking for resources
on with experience on cloud computing as
well
now in terms of career path I believe
most of you have this set of you know
kind of this question that I have four
years of experience and working as XYZ
what job I can get in cloud or and do
not have any experience will I have any
chances etcetera and so on so what we
have done is we have kind of created a
career path for you depending upon your
current experience level depending upon
how experienced you are on the cloud
computing side as well so you will say
it can depend upon whether if you have
no experience no awareness at all on the
cloud the roles that that you should
ideally target should be either a junior
developer role or a junior segment goals
typically there are roles available in
the market you know depending upon
whether you are more interested in being
a developer or more interested in being
a system admin guy who will probably be
working on let's just your storage your
servers your databases and so on so
depending upon your interest level if
you are a bigger if you are a pressure
if you do not have any experience
whatsoever what I would recommend is
first of all you need to have a passion
on what you want to learn so you need to
choose a path whether you want to be a
developer or whether you want to be a so
admin guy if you are more comfortable in
the coding world then go for the
developer if you are not there are
people who are not comfortable in coding
I am one of them I never like coding in
my life so I you know chooses a path for
myself that I want to be more into the
you know infrastructure side rather than
being on the coding side so if you are
on the infrastructure side then you
should typically be targeting a job like
a junior system admin but typically a
junior system admin role that they say
that anyone with zero to two years of
experience now of course if you go
through any of the simpler courses and
if you clear your
education on AWS you will definitely
have an edge over other people who may
not have any experience on cloud who may
not have any relevant experience on you
know cloud as well so if you have a
basic understanding you if you have no
awareness to basic understanding of
cloud these are the two job roles that
should ideally be targeting and then if
you have approximately you know two to
four to two to five years experience
then you can again have a panel role of
a developer or a system admin again
based on whether you are recording where
it's very real to coding or where they
are to infrastructure now then we have a
role which is primarily called cloud
engineer now this particular particular
role is I would say it's a combination
of a development side and a system admin
side as well
our I will not say that you need to
learn coding to become a cloud engineer
but the way industry is moving there are
a lot of focus on automation there is a
lot of focus on you know things like
artificial intelligence IOT big data
etcetera and so on so if you really want
to progress in your career
so apart from learning stuff on AWS
cloud or any combat Materazzi road and
so on I would recommend that you learn
one scripting language any scripting
language scripting language is not equal
to coding so if you are thinking that
you I just said that I don't like coding
so scripting is not equal to coding
scripting is probably as close to the
coding as it gets however this is not
cooling if you have worked as a system
admin if you have deployed a server if
you have the prior to switch if you had
applied and out there on a firewall you
know the commands that you normally give
to get apply some stuff it is equivalent
to learning those commands and then
putting those commands together in one
single document and then running the
document again okay so to work on one
script if you ask me recommendation on
one what one scripting language that
actually I should be targeting if you
are going to work on it up less clouds I
would suggest that you should learn JSON
scripting JSON scripting is probably
your best bet going into the AWS cloud
environment and
Lord Jason's then at least learn a UNIX
scripting UNIX scripting or shell
scripting are probably going to be the
most basic scripting languages which you
can learn but if you want to get a
little advanced then I would recommend
JSON scripting so these are the three
scripting language that I want to leave
you with depending upon which one you
want to pick I would totally leave it up
to you now once you have a 5 to 9 years
of experience if you cross that range so
7 to 10 8 to 15 or 12 up to 12 years of
experience of course there are other
rules available like DevOps engineer or
a cloud solution architect or a DevOps
architect on a cloud consultant as well
DevOps architect or a cloud consultant
slash slope solution architect slash
your cloud archetypal primarily you need
to have bare minimum eight to ten years
of experience normally companies do not
hire with any experience less than eight
to ten years for these rules and these
ones you will can only apply if you
already have at least eight to ten years
of experience even though if you do not
have any experience on cloud however not
having any experience on cloud and
applying for cloud consultant or the
cloud architect role may not you know
queue onto the spot we not you know get
you that three calls so of course if you
have a solution architect certification
that probably can help you you know
cross that path as well right now DevOps
engineer or at when we talked about that
was in the road above socket we are
looking at a kind of cobble made or a
combination of a developer as well as a
in cluster guy again this is something
that you can get into only if you learn
at least one scripting language of code
there are other tools which are
available if you have worked on any of
your tools during your life then
probably you have more senses as well
so cloud architect as I said there are
experience will be around 8 to 15 years
that's a typical experience range that
numbed companies ask for a cloud
architect salary can range anywhere
between 90 to 60 90 to 160 key that you
are talking about us numbers right now
typically what they ask is that you
should know at least basics of cloud
coding that working database levels
change
and so on and then in terms of courses
which can map or which you can go
through which it should be the targeting
in case if you want to get into you know
if you want to get into cloud architect
tool is either first things in terms of
basics you should ideally be doing a
Julia stack essential or CP hundred a
which is basically or Google technical
essential and then we have introduced as
you're depending upon which cloud
platform that you want to progress into
and then you will have to go for
solution architects certifications again
we have these certifications in each of
this platform AWS goggle and s0 and then
we have the AWS sa professional but this
is probably the most tough examination
that you will come across this is a
three hour exam and typically as I said
you need to have at least you know more
than two to a couple of years of
experience on UW's cloud before you
achieve a pair for solution accurate
professional so of course if you become
an SI professional you need to know a
lot of stuff not only about a degrees
but also about security network cost
reliability performance I availability
fault all those operational excellence
and then some of the you know other
industry top as well like Big Daddy Big
Data IOT accept and so on so this is how
a typical rule of a cloud architect will
progress so from technical essential to
solution accurate than working have some
level of work experience on the cloud
and then only you can appear for a cloud
architect profiling then we have a cloud
engineer typical experience range of
five to nine years cell range between 90
K to 119 120 K again in terms of course
mapping you do need have to have some
level of basics in terms of
infrastructure in terms of coding and
then technical essential or intro to 0
or intro to Google cloud and then
followed by your developer associate or
you're developing reso certification or
CPD 200 so primarily what we are going
into is that if you are into development
background there is a separate track for
you if you are in infrastructure
background there is a separate track for
you so for developers
you should ideally be going for you know
force like AWS developer as you see
or developing in either a zero for your
CPD 200 that's your developers course on
Google platform and then you can also go
for AWS shops so in case if you are from
intros itself you have a cyst offset so
here you have implementing in Azure and
you have CPU 200 which is equal to your
operations on in Google cloud and then
you do need to learn about git
repositories of all bit buckets about
doctors about Jenkins so these are some
of the tools that typically your cloud
engineers uses in their day-to-day life
then we have DevOps ingenious probably
one rule which is very very very common
these days and probably the most posted
job openings these days on cloud
computing is going to be about DevOps
engineers or demos professionals so in
this case it is a combination of your
you know as I said development or
developer as well as your your
infrastructure skills so you do need to
go through AWS technical essential or a
basic essentials on a zero or Google
Plus you need to be developer associate
plus you need to know little bit on edge
a agile scrum master doctor DevOps
practitioner so these are different
courses which are available within
scintillant
in case if you want to target a job run
off a DevOps engineer or a divorce
professionals right there are some
electives as well in terms of there are
when we talk about I'm just covering
those electives but primarily what we
mean by elective is that you can have
some level of you know skills at some
level of expertise in any of these
specific courses as well for example you
may have an expertise on MongoDB or
Python or we have expertise on Linux or
eBay or expertise on kids and kinship
etcetera and so on so depending upon
assuming that you would have work on any
of these tools in case if you are
applying you know appearing for dev of
Store so the point that I want to make
is that for any of these job roles this
in case if you want to target these job
roles first of all help is available
there are relevant courses which are
available on similar platform that in
case
if you want to go for it and second be
getting into those jobs we will need an
effort from the other side as well in
terms of money in terms of definitely
your time as well and most importantly
that please be very very clear of the
rule that you want to target you should
not be targeting each and every job but
that's not possible for one single
resource so first of all find out if you
are a fresher find out where your
passion lies whether you are more
comfortable on you know progressing your
career on development side although
you're more comfortable on progressing
your career on setup side both whether
you become a developer whether you
become a sun-soaked you can have your
own career progression as well so don't
worry about that
and secondly if you are an experienced
resource if you are already working in
the industry try to find out what are
your complementary complimenting skills
that can help you in it in any of the
cloud platform based on what you already
have based on the expertise that you
already have then select which course or
which particular you know calculon which
probably be you know adding value to
your existing profile as well right so
quickly goes to the market trend again
so this is something that we have
covered so when you're talking about I
think there is a repetitive slides we
have already covered that but this is a
separate study from another you know
what you call another obvious idea
magazines as well which basically says
that your public load model is going to
grow up to 173 B and there is weather
study which was talking about 220
billion class whereas when we talk about
sass and flash past portions of there we
will discuss about public and private
cloud here they are discussing public
cloud with sass and pass providers so
sass and tax provider are expected to
grow at 55 billion by 2026 as well if
you look at the different cloud
providers so within public cloud I said
the major cloud providers available in
the market today is eight obvious as
your and Google Cloud and AWS is
probably the number one cloud provider
in the market today in fact if if you
look at the Gartner report of 2017 to
got a report was published on June 2017
for infrastructure as a service model
AWS has been designated as a leader in
Gartner for info scale as a service
model for seventh consecutive year so
from last seven years AWS has been the
number one cloud provider in the market
which is closely being followed or which
is your the most the closest competitor
to AWS is going to be your s your Google
Cloud is catching up but probably I will
say that will take them at least couple
of years or maybe more than couple of
years to get into the leaders quadrant
but if you look at the public cloud
eight of this as your and Google are the
most common providers in the market
today in terms of private cloud we have
definitely we have public cloud from
other companies and IBM has their own
public law firm they still ocean has
their own public cloud offerings we have
a public cloud offering from box we have
a public cloud option from Oracle cloud
as well but they are not as big as of
the other top provider that we have
talked about right so this also does
this this infographic also gives a very
very interesting insights as well so
even though AWS has been the number one
cloud provider in the market from last
seven years
but if you look at the year-on-year
number so 2016 was a 2017 you would
notice that AWS has been pretty flat
whereas if you look at the numbers of
azure or the Google so is your from
twenty percent they have captured the
market at 34 percent Google from 10
percent has moved on to 15 percent and
so on so this shows that the other cloud
cloud providers are also coming up with
their own innovation with coming up with
their own price advantages and so on and
they are catching up as well right but
still AWS has continued to be number one
they have the early mover advantage over
the first public saw which was launched
so they still are going at a decent
click as well right so this is where we
are discussed top of the cloud provider
so it obvious continues to you know to
top the chart followed by Azure and
VMware vCloud air so even though this is
the number 4 provider but recently there
has been a new development in VMware as
well so VMware has signed an agreement
we have entered into a partnership with
AWS and they are going to come up with
the VMware vCenter powered cloud on a
yes platform so I don't think so that
VMware will continue to invest on their
own data centers going forward they are
going to use AWS data centers going
forward so AWS and VMware has partnered
and probably you will see VMware vCenter
power cloud from early 2018 you should
be able to deploy your VMware
infrastructure directly on it appears as
well right alright so with that I would
pause on for a moment and I would take
any of the question that you may have
before passing on the presenting rights
to you know my other click from the pro
as well now I have seen that you have
posted a lot of questions I have
specifically chosen go to your attempt
those questions at all so what I will do
is I will read out those questions one
by one and I'll answer those questions
but you can continue to you know type in
your question as well
all right so question from Archie so
what are the job levels for the staff
already with 15 years of experience well
I hope that your question has been
answered ashish as as i said that reason
I was kind of ignoring those questions
are because I know that those questions
will already be answered in the upcoming
slide again question from ashes what if
I have 10 years of experience but I
would like to move to cloud mean then we
would have fix again I have answered
your question there are different rules
there are different courses which are
available depending upon what your
existing skill set is depending upon
where you currently stand in the market
and what course you want to enroll into
you can get in to plug them in as well
all right question from Ashok what is
the difference between cloud solution
architect and cloud consultant I would
say there are different rules but
primarily in terms of roles and
responsibilities it is one of the same
thing it is primarily a priest preacher
soul I mean some companies can code can
call them a slow solution architect
others may call it as cloud consultant
question for machi salary part what
about in India as you have mentioned
with respect to us so what so India is
an interesting market because typically
u.s. is pretty open when it comes to
sharing the salary data but India we
normally not do not share our salary
data that's what probably you've not
seen many studies
they're in the market which are talking
about the salary data as far as India is
concerned however it totally depends on
your total experience so if I have to
give you a very very general rule of
thumb and that's how you know probably
when we take interviews we also kind of
you know come up with you know what will
be the right price range for a candidate
is so rule of thumb this that is you
multiply your total number of years with
two that would be the average salary of
an of an IT resource now you may have
some niche skills which others may not
have and in that kid that number that
that multiple can go up to two point
five as well so somebody with the ten
years of experience should expect a
salary range of 20 to 25 that I would
say depending upon their existing skill
set depending upon their existing cell
rate depending upon what level of
expertise they have on a different cloud
platform okay question from such an do I
have a chance to make my career in a
degree a solution architect from after
moving from a variety of IT experience
which can be SAT or excellent now an IT
coordinator but definitely you may have
an opportunity typically as I said
solution architect is probably the most
coveted role you need to have some level
of expertise on AWS if you have not
worked on cloud at all then probably
getting into a solution architect would
be a very very tough job to crack but
what I would recommend is that first of
all you need to have some level of
working experience you pick up a role
which is more of a you know cloud
deployment yield or a cloud projected
etcetera and so on get some level of
experience and then apply powerful
solution architect code right now if you
will apply for a role just by clearing
your player your exam probably it is not
going to be as simple as it is as it
looks like because companies are looking
at actual experience rather than your
just the certifications or a question
form they then check the new operator
form and found there are jobs available
in cloud computing but with experience
days between eight to ten and twelve
twelve so guys I have already
that there are different roles available
there are experiences of eight to ten
ten to twelve ten to fifteen there are
experiences you are ranging from zero to
five as well so totally depends on your
total year total years of experience and
what is the job that you are targeting
so rejected if you have worked in telco
cloud and have 10 year with 10 years
experience your industry does not matter
what matters is what exactly you have
worked into that industry and what else
what what all you have learned on clouds
how much working experience you have in
the cloud so you should I mean if you
have a 10 year experience and you know
the JSON and any scripting I would say
that cloud engineer or a you know a
cloud engineer or a cloud deployment is
in your rules would be the one that you
should be targeting alright guys so
there are sixty plus participants which
are available so I'm not I I will not be
in a position to give you career advice
for individual to all of you so what we
have done is we have tired of you know
given you details at a very very high
level now what I am going to do is we
are tired of on top of an R so what I'm
going to do now is I am going to pass on
the presenting rights back to industries
who can you know forward those
presenting rights to him er who may be
able to answer more of your questions on
specifically on the job roles
alright and a month listed can you pass
on the presenting rights to human please
Jonathan thank you so much Nathan thank
you and as there is a great shift in
technology I believe that everything is
moving on cloud and in another five
years almost every large company will be
moving their application to the cloud
and another good thing is that most of
the company's oriented in finance
applications are also moving to the
cloud based applications because the
security standards are proven to be a
really safe in cloud and I believe that
Nitin has given a great insight are
today and it was fantastic Nitin I have
learned a lot today because not being
from cloud or AWS background still I
could get
it most of these stuff today and it is
it was really really beneficial and I
have learned a lot and I believe that
all people who are present in webinar
today would have got much insights and
of course we will be having more queries
on job asses and how their career is
going to take an u-turn or maybe like a
new turn after these certifications so I
think that payment will also be able to
take up some of the equations but listen
it was really fantastic and wonderful
session thank you so much for giving
your time on weekend thank you for your
presence nothing like welcome so are not
taking much of your time I would like to
give present access to payment as I said
I said that I really feel fortunate that
I could invite him on an intimate has
accepted our invite to come in this
session on weekend and just to provide
you people all kind of assistance that
he can our guidance that he can provide
on interview questions or maybe he would
like to tell you that what you should do
to put your first impression in
interviews I I believe that this is also
going to be really really beneficial for
all of us to have him with us so I'm
just giving present erectors to Haman hi
Haman the Irie order bill to you hi I'm
Alan yes so thanks
mushiya for talking on the telly tonight
and it only does water for listening to
heard session I personally have learned
a lot of things which I was not aware
earlier and moving ahead da I'll take
you to click maybe a maximum of 10
minutes on all of your time and tell you
how you love to prepare for an interview
and how what an ideal thing which you
might do and that might be you know
probably
oh yeah Dudley you know help you crackin
will do so on I'm closing my chat screen
because of a few technical issues but
I'll make sure I'll answer all the
questions at the end of my session so to
introduce myself I'm humans I work as an
executive in talent acquisition I
currently work for the Pro technologies
so I hired for a lot of divisions
starting from before digital the place
CTO office the chief technology office
and we have a lot of decisions which we
hired under our team's name these are
the transformations that there is a lot
of work which is being done on cloud
computing must be on AWS and we have a
new division which is a new company
which is which we have taken over called
optical cloud services which we are
which we hired and also we hired a GUI
for a product called offloaded so we can
connect upon Linden on Linden or
compression and Cal I'd like to answer
all the questions here and in case if we
need any further connection in future
also we can come into fondant it sure
don't at that I only believe in the code
that is mentioned on my screen so people
say that where there is a bill dealt
away but I say that there is a still
there's a way so so define kill I think
skin is everything so if you can see
proper English it's still proper tell
you it's a specific and proper finding
skilled joke man so anything which you
master then a called acting
so all you guys who finished an AWS
trainee so AWS is currently a skill so
anyone who's mastered in something is
equal to
you know getting a job today's like an
expert skill is equal to an XO job think
that I am new head with the products
life where I've been seeking mentioning
how do you have to prepare a parent
interview also so I say that in hostile
first sit back and understand water your
skill whether your experiences whether
your qualities from which you come them
right also the when I say the skill I
meant the expertise in dazzle to some
some some people live excess in Java
some people are exceptions web let a lab
us assured or anything like that so
student is something that you are an
expert in so the experiences is which
your education your experiences and
qualities is what you'll have to first
sit down and understand me sit down and
understand first before you even prepare
your CV so once you getting some clarity
on what are your top two skills then
we'll have to start preparing that CD so
an identity is something which is of
Vantage so a recruiter thankfully most
of the recruiters doesn't understand
technology right so they are both at
most of the tech recruiters go with
keywords
very tank when you prepare a very brief
CD of not say a page and highlight the
top skills which you have in yet which
have been working in your career as the
target of getting shortlisted for a
particular job role is very very high so
my position is a single third TV
mentioning the highlights of the part
most experiences which we have a large
tablet and next is will you'll have to
make sure that you understand
the JD before we broke up any any
interview so you're not been you
understand a duty or the Job Description
which have a grouper shared with you so
you shouldn't exceed the amount of
questions of the relevant questions
which an interviewer asked you and my
suggestion is if you are applying for
suppose you are a Java developer and you
you've been working on AWS for last six
months and you've applied for an AWS
developer role I suggest you should keep
the AWS experience search and then the
Java experience so so that the chances
of getting the shipper CV shortlisted is
very very high so so that is the main
thing that you'll have to make sure when
were sadly preparing your CD then the
next most important point is when you
are attending an interview once the PD
is plugging shortlisted and we are
wrapping an interview you should do a
deep dive into how the organization but
how awesome Broadway it was what is its
culture and what is its we are working
for example I can take this example of
top coder so popular was one of the
organizations which we have recently
taken over so top earner has its unique
style of working with this company so
much of the people most of the panelists
I can say from TopCoder they're
accepting more than the technical part
of it they that accepting people go to
Capulet that can't sign up understand
habit verbs
understand how you know you can feel a
part of it
that is their 70s with getting their
impress than the technical part of it
should then I see and technical
interview comments I I see the top
comments would be the status can't have
so the conduct has signed up Intifada
calm and and actually have done some
work on top so the show
I prefer this can develop any other
bandit so getting that instance I meant
to say that you have to probably get
into depth of any any job you're getting
into
for example if you are applying for the
division calls it for digital you can go
back to them and check them the
tradition was formed when the Apple you
know early accessiblestl is working on
what that it's quicker culture what is
its values and things like that so first
so this is a major and important factor
which you have to do because you work
for an interview then then you punch you
get in repair your TV shot list do some
research you will definitely have to
practice before the compare and
interview practice is the most key
factor which made for yourself confident
especially at junior level people who
are pressures - let's say totally worth
experienced mesh of them most of them
get nervous in the integers so to make
sure that you don't get nervous you will
have to you'll have to go sit down relax
and practice so this is being told by
one of my mentors that you'll have to go
sit in front of a mirror and practice
how you speak in terms of an interview
so so practice is one major thing which
every I think every individual has to do
it before team or she attention entities
so moving on so this is what you will
have to make sure you you you do before
and on the day of formal TV so on the
day of an interview you should make sure
that you you have you just double your
tribe the neat clean and bring a comment
or interview because the first
impression of an interviewer after
seeing a candidate or a perception
changes the decision-making position
making
- integers so the most important thing
is you will have to you know make sure
that the first impression is always
clarity so it mostly the first
impression of an integral happens you
are closing your superior body language
through the various speak to the
descriptors interviewers on the day of
the interview and I'm you should know
yourself better so that I would you you
mentioned on the resume you should make
sure that you can answered any anything
you know which is mentioned on the
resume so so I what I can tell you is
that you should of uses whatever the
summary or the whatever think she's done
values activated on the summary tab
occurred which will take one-third of
the first which the first part of the
one first which should be where
somebody's bed add recruited we'll go
through the summary and then probably
slightly make a perception on your
profile then you have to know the job
profile where the company as I was
telling you earlier and I I wished on
Talmadge not to say anything on the
resume so most of the res image which
which come up to us most of them my
capital sometimes even the gender is not
edited so I will request most of my
peers we're linking to this webinar are
not to fit anything in their resume and
also at the part of the interview
process I will either this everyone to
ask questions only when you ask
questions to the recruiter the
interviewers or the other peers their
peers I'd better go interview day only
then they feel that you are dealing
except you take of this opportunity
if you don't ask questions you getting a
job role yes regarding here you know the
day how
the company's words that will be what
will be the sultry that will be as you
know expectations out of the job you'll
have to ask questions to the recruiters
only then the thing that you are really
interested in taking of these
opportunities so that is what is what my
experiences and I will part of sharing
with you guys and yeah now I am open for
personal bankers I just opened my chat
window he uses that
hello among time on you took out
computing and AWS and I don't have any
experience in any field as high pressure
so when making a CD do I have to mention
that I know easy to be PC boot yeah
definitely yes so I suggest you guys to
suggest you to page to set keep all
these tools on the resume so make sure
that so that is what I will study there
as a part of my presentation that please
do not take anything okay so if you are
perfect that you know that you are an
expert in this kind of a scale you
should does not be put on your resume
and that will definitely add on to that
you know the best I mean the chance of
selecting will be very high especially
you think you can ask to answer your
question so this is what should be the
best analogy that separation of PD as a
quote I assure the so salute it ie think
the basic things which are to be
highlighted on a resume should be we
have a visitor summary the main
important thing so the rest of
experience that you have that soft key
skills which you've been working on in
your last few years of your carrier the
top vehicle sentiment a thought I
seriously say that you should be an
expert in its own then
okay you've been hiding multiple kind of
or earlier - there will be a lot of
people who who come up with lot of
keywords Buddhists randomly picked a lot
of keywords in the resume just to make
sure that the will to make a chart
listed that the first thing which
interval asks the part of the candidate
is that web web appearances - in for
example if someone has written that
there as well from natural language
processing then altogether the first
question which he will ask is whether
you do one natural language processing
what they did one machine learning so
that is a main thing so path to skills
is a most important thing and then the
next thing which you can do is put an
annex assertion anacs anacs chat section
and then the recruiter that if needed I
believe I'll be able to provide you a
detailed you know annex or of the
products which are well done and you can
get a copy of furniture to the interview
and give it to the technical bundle
because most of that thing which is
where manager or the product is dealing
with at a buyer
interviewer another recruiter so so I I
others that you have to put a cup date
column called amateur and mentioned that
this can be given on request and
probably get it on the interview day I
thank you so much Raymond time to very
much I believe that we do have more
questions coming in I would suggest all
of the participants word online today
are to mail me at job assist at simply
learn dot ne D so that I can actually
forwarded to him and also so that he can
answer a few of your queries so I'll be
more than happy to answer your queries
regarding job assist and please forward
all your queries to job assist accent
Leland dot any Lee I'll be taking you
through how to submit your profile on
job asus portal and I believe that he
meant whatever you covered today was
really really helpful just because most
of
when I send the resume zuv our
candidates or learners to the companies
they screen the series and sometimes it
is really kind of difficult for me why
it gets rejected in screening parts so I
got much of the input so wherever
whenever I am forwarding some of the
templates to our learner I will keep in
mind that I need to prepare a kind of
template as you suggested today that
they need to highlight their skills that
they are covering in this particular
technology all certification that they
are doing with us in the very beginning
of their resume a because sometimes they
tend to include each and everything at
the beginning of resume a which makes a
very easy screen reject just because a
recruiter is not able to connect where
they have how they have covered their
technologies in AWS so I believe that
all of us today were online I have got
much insights how to create your resume
one second when you are going for the
interview you should always know about
the company and you should always know
about the organization for which you are
going to attend for your interview so it
was really fantastic thank you so much
chairman for giving your time in weekend
today and thank you so much for
accepting my request to come and be
session today thank you so much and as I
detailed first also that whosoever is
having more queries can forward their
queries to job assist at simply learned
George ne T so that we can address your
queries thank you so much human thank
you thanks Michelle
I think I love the atomization Thank You
humans and Nitin all right on the script
I'm just passing on the present axis to
you and you can take it over from here
all right our participants I would
request you to wait for a while the
street has some important details to
share with all of you okay so the street
is taking over from here thank you
everybody for your input thank you so
much I hope my screen is also visible to
all of you okay so just to give you all
a glance that
so we are in process of partnering with
most of the companies and the brands so
that we'll be able to give you good
assistance on job assist and we'll be
able to forward your resumes to most of
the companies and I'm in process of
partnering with most of them and Wipro
was one of them so that I could call
with pros partner just to give you a
brief about your resume a outline as
well as what you should cover and what
are we do in terms of interview so just
to make you all aware that once you get
your project evaluated you might be
having some of the projects in your
course so once you get all your projects
evaluated and you receive a final score
of 80 or more percentage and you need to
have a completion certificate in your
hand before applying for job assist just
because if you are in process of taking
a your certificate you can still upload
your resume in job Asus portal but I
suggest you all to please upload your
resume once you have certificate in your
hand and you have already completed your
projects just because when I talk about
hands-on experience simply learn is
giving you best platform in which you
when you learn about some technology and
you do your hand sewn on practicals then
it becomes very much relevant for you
people to include those particular
details in your resume so that is why we
say that you can include all these
project details in resume a to make it
more impressive so when you work upon
project and you include all the
technologies that you have used to
complete that project it gives really
good impression to the recruiter and it
makes you a step ahead of all the
pressure as I have got some of the
question in which I I actually am sorry
I just didn't get the name on that a
person was asking if he or she is a
fresher how can they apply for good jobs
and what are the opportunities so I
just like to mention that when you're
doing the certification from San Julian
you're already a step ahead from the
normal pressures who are graduating or
poles graduating from the school and
getting some knowledge on awl just
because you will be having hands-on
experience working on the projects and
you will be well-versed on the
technologies when the equations are
asked on telephone also like in
telephonic interviews you will be in
position to answer them properly and
much better than the pressures so don't
worry about all that and when you
compete your projects and get your final
score and get your certification in hand
you just need to go on this particular
site that is mentioned on this line
simply run George combs or buses so when
you'll go here you can submit your
profile it will ask you for your
username and password and then you just
need to click on in drawl once you click
on in drawl it will just ask you that
which particular course you're taking
your first name just answer all your our
questions here
you
you
humans you can go on mute please thank
you
if you are ready to relocate please are
just click on yes option if you are not
ready to relocate and you are searching
for some opportunities in your own city
then please just click on no because it
will help me sort out the resume when I
get some of the job requirements from
different locations so as I am
experiencing nowadays that some of the
candidates who are having family in some
city they might not be interested in
moving out of that particular city
because they might be working there
partner why it might be working so when
I call them they if they click on yes it
becomes like somewhat confusing for me
that I can forward the resume of a
person who is staying in Bangalore for
Pune location as well but then at the
end moment when I come to know that it
is not possible for the the candidate to
relocate it becomes like kind of
difficult for me to just take out the
resume a once I forward it to the
company so please be conscious when you
are replying to this particular answer
so just click on yes if you are ready to
relocate so that if I am getting
opportunities from different locations I
can forward your or I can consider your
resume a for that too
you
you
you
now again when I'm talking about
relevant experience it means that you're
working on particular technology from
how many years like you can mention zero
to two years also so that I will be
knowing that it's just zero to one year
of experience that you have completed
the certification and now you are
working on some of the projects so I can
actually look for some of the
opportunities which are calling for
freshers so we can always mention
relevant experience and as I have got
one more question here that if I have
experience of approximately five to six
years in some different domain but my
relevant experience would be zero to one
years or maybe like two to three years
because I have been working in this
technology that I am taking the
certification on for one to two years so
we just mentioned that particular thing
in your total experience and your
relevant experience so you can always
mention your current employers name
and your current designation again it
helps me when I screen your resume if it
is for senior profile I just need to
screen it from my site before forwarding
it to the company just because some time
it is mentioned in the job description
that which kind of profiles they are
looking for and what is the position
that they are going to offer sometimes
it depends upon the interview after
interview they decide and they give you
a kind of option that for which position
they are considering you so sometimes it
depends upon the interview or else at
the very prior stage I get it in job
descriptions as well
you
again sometimes when I get the
requirement they usually ask that if you
are forwarding the resumes of your
learner's the just mention their current
CTC and they're expected CTC so not it
becomes easier for them to screen your
resume because once they open your
resumes they might not be knowing how
much is your current CTC because usually
we don't mention current CTC and
expected CPC in our su-mei and I I also
don't suggest you all to mention this
particular thing in your resume because
it should it should be a equation that
should be asked from the employer when
they are interviewing you or maybe it is
more related to the HR in your technical
grounds also they usually don't ask
about your current CTC n expected CPC
you need to mention your notice period
because usually we do have IT companies
who give you enough a letter or two
months of notice period and sometimes
you do have three months of thirties
period as well so if I have some of the
companies who would like immediate
joiners then I might not forward your
profile to them just because if it is
immediate joining then they might take
your interview and after that it becomes
like really bad on our part that we
forward your resume even when we know
that you'll be having two months of
notice period if the companies already
like they are flexible enough to take
you or to give you some kind of options
like buyout
then I can forward your resumes to them
so please mention your your notice
period and then at the last you just
need to upload your file from here like
you just need to upload your resume so
that it will be available with me in my
database so I would like you all to take
to just upload your resume and once you
update your as you may also you can now
upload it again
you
you
you
you
so this is how you need to forward your
resume and upload your resume n-- job
asus portal as i mentioned that you all
need to just upload your resume and it
will be available with me in the
database hello sorry for the disturbance
hi everyone can you all hear me
thanks to them
any question from your side I would love
to add take over some of the equations
if you have regarding job assist it is
mentioned on the slide as well job
assist at simply learn comm you can
forward your queries to that any quick
questions that you would like me to
address
you
do we need to submit our CV after
completing these central on certificate
as I mentioned you can submit you can
upload your resume before also but I
would suggest you to please complete
your project so that you can include
your project experience as well in your
resume and this will give me a clear
idea as well that you have complete
completed your certificate because the
job assistance assistance will be
provided once you get certificate in
your hand so you can always upload your
resume before completion of your
certification as well but I will be able
to assist you for or I will be able to
forward your resumes to the companies
after completion of your certificate
only so once you get the certificate in
hand after that only I will be able to
assist you for so should we create
profile now while doing the course or
after getting some again same answer
that you can create your profile and you
can upload your resume on our job as
portal before completion of your
certification as well but I'll suggest
you to please complete your
certification because I will be able to
assist you for the opportunities once
you compete and get your certification
in hand because once you upload your
resume also I check whether you complete
your completed your certificate or not
only then I forward the resumes because
I do have a system in which it
automatically get tested that you have
completed your certification or not so
once you upload your resume a also it
get tested that the completion
certificate is issued to you if not then
I'll be I will not be able to forward
your resume into the company so this
option that is submit resume not
available for UW a system of cieth
learners I think this is a particular
course so that is why it might not be
available and it is not showing in the
page so should I proceed with aw a
solution architect exam will it here
yeah of course like a aw a solution
architect exam if you'll clear that exam
and you get the certification in hand it
is simply learned certificate that I am
talking about so
once you complete your project that is
included in these are simply learned
scores then you get simply done
certification in your hand and you can
upload your resume so that is why I told
you about the eligibility criteria that
you people need to need to keep in your
mind are you are we going to get the
recording of session yes pravin you will
be getting the recording of the session
I will be creating a youtube link and I
will be sharing that youtube link with
all of you and maybe next are three to
four days so I'll be sharing the
recording of the session with you all so
that anytime you want to refer the
recording it will be available with you
no worries thank you so much perfectly
fine so I'll be taking all your queries
from job assist at simply Lancome so you
can forward me your queries on the same
email id thank you so much for your
presence and I believe that decision was
really helpful to you and it was as
expected thank you everyone thank you
thanks thanks everybody everything
you'll be getting all the DVDs all the
whole presentation will be converted
into youtube link and I will be sharing
that link with you thank you everyone
thank you thank you nice treat for such
a wonderful session and on providing us
the insights about the job assist and
the current scope of AWS in the market
alright participants I hope all your
queries are being resolved by a trainer
as well as Haman and if you have in case
any further doubts and queries you can
always write to us on job assisted rates
employer comm or.net we are available
for in order to resolve your queries all
right with that let us stop sharing our
screen and the like if there are not no
further doubts and queries you can go
ahead and log out of the session thank
you so much for joining us